[Musique]
bonjour d'oriens alexandre 41 ans
président et fondateur de mécatronique
ce méta tronics est une entreprise il
transforme la science fiction et réalité
aujourd'hui nous avons un produit qui
s'appelle visionnaire pro qui est un
système de vidéoconférence par l'une est
connecté et ce système permet la
téléportation de compétences d'un
endroit à l'autre de la planète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une entreprise qui va rayonner au
niveau de l'océan indien
je compte commencer par la réunion
ensuite par maurice et ensuite le reste
de l'afrique australe alors en jeu
concours dans la catégorie start up car
en fait produit est un produit qui est
unique
aujourd'hui à la réunion nous le
démarrons donc dans le but c'est de
créer des emplois en interne de
maytronics mais aussi à l'extérieur
alors avant de créer mechatronics
j'étais responsable informatique dans
une grande entreprise réunion pour la
création d'entreprise est aidé par un
expert comptable pas réunion
entreprendre et par ma banque
ce que m'apporte la position de chef
d'entreprise il ya beaucoup de
responsabilités et beaucoup de travail à
fournir
il faut aussi être fort au niveau
émotionnel et haut niveau la ténacité il
faut être bien entouré d'un accompagné
je vais gagner le challenge du créateur
car mon produit visionnaire pro va
pouvoir servir à créer de l'emploi dans
de nouvelles fonctions de la
télémédecine l'industrie et il va
pouvoir aussi aider à réduire les
émissions carbone grâce au fait ne plus
avoir besoin d'utiliser des moyens de
transport pour se déplacer d'un endroit
à un autre
[Musique]
laetitia poser aboudou 36 ans présidente
de la société notre box
[Musique]
boxe c'est un service d'abonnement à une
box beauté surprise donc ça veut dire
que les abonnés reçoivent un colis chez
elle tous les mois un petit cadeau
qu'elles se font elles ne connaissent
strictement rien au contenu de ce colis
à l'intérieur il ya toujours quatre à
six produits de beauté et accessoires
tantôt mois un produit local est un
produit bio et ses produits sont adaptés
au profil de la cliente
quand il s'y prête par exemple si vous
avez un shampoing le shampoing va être
adapté à votre nature de chez vous j'ai
décidé de concourir dans la catégorie
start-up parce que nous de boxe est un
concept que j'ai rapporté à la réunion
qui n'existait pas jusqu'à l'or qui
fonctionne très bien aux états unis et
en europe et qui a été validé puisque
nous existons depuis un an nous avons
déjà 230 abonnés qui pour la plupart
pris un engagement sur 12 mois et
surtout elle répond à une spécificité
qui est notre météo qui a versé par
rapport à l'europe avant de créer mon
entreprise j'ai travaillé 14 ans en
e-commerce en métropole je suis rentré
il ya deux ans pour suivre mon conjoint
et n'ayant pas d'emploi j'ai eu l'idée
de créer ma société
j'ai eu la chance aussi de
concourir à un concours organisé par la
mairie de saint paul a le coup de pouce
aux initiatives locales pour laquelle
j'ai été lauréate et qui m'a valu une
subvention la position des chefs
d'entreprise
elle a cet avantage non négligeable
quand on est une femme de pouvoir gérer
sa vie de famille en toute liberté
malgré tout ça reste quand même
énormément de travail et beaucoup de
stress mais c'est une situation qui est
très challenge en tête- qui permet de
concilier l'ambition et l'amour de la
famille je vais gagner le challenge des
créateurs parce que je suis motivé que
j'aime mes clientes que j'ai envie de
mettre la réunion en l'air comme on dit
et surtout je pense que notre box a un
fort potentiel de développement dans
tous les autres territoires ultramarins
[Musique]